9時で終わりに時間になりますが
少しだけでしたら次を伺うことができますので
もしどうしても聞きたいことございましたら挙手していただけましょう
えーと 何かご質問ございますでしょうか
えーと 特にご質問の方はいらっしゃらないです
あ はい はい どうぞ  理性って使ってられてる理性っていうのは
また理性っていうのは実際何を意味するのかな
データにデータから判断するとかね
まあ感情的にならないこととかね
もうそんな程度でしょう
単純ですよ 例えばコロナにあるでしょ
私以外他の神を信仰したらただで済みませんよ
絶対に許さないんだよ
無言でしょ あんた以外神がいるのか
あんた優秀な神でしょう
単純でしょう だからそういう風に何か見ると何か発見するの面白いんですよ
それが理性っていうことなんです
私はこの状況から出てるんだけど
一応 例えば神が怒った人間がね
もうそれを犯したと だったら神が悪いでしょう
なんで突如怒られた人間が悪いんですか？だからまあ
そういう風にどんなことでも考えると
理性なんて面白いです
はい 他のご質問がいかがでしょうか
あります はい  時間だからみんな気にしているかもしれません
じゃあ終了しましょうか
今日私は早く終わると思っていたんで
はいはい どうぞ  マイクありますけど
映画とかで感情でも誰かを
感情の話なんですけど
えっと 映画とかでとても大好きな人がいて
ずっと思い続けてたりとか
そういうこう なんか綺麗な
で 私は捉えてたんですけど
そういう感情も悪感情
それは貪瞋痴か不貪不瞋痴かと判断しなくちゃいけないんですね
ただ 普通は悪感情で しかし
この献身的で貢献的で慈しみで
例えば映画でね 一人一人が一生懸命苦労して人々を育てるというか
例えばこのユダヤの人々を助けた映画といろいろあるでしょう
一生懸命人を助けてあげたりとかね
その時なんとなく感動するんですね
ただの映画なんですけど
その場合は人が死ななくてよかったとかね
命助けられてよかったというね
それは悪感情にはならないんですね
しかし あのラスベガスのカジノに行って
いきなり大金回ってきてとか
それはもう悪感情で そういうストーリーだったら
すごい大金入って もう今まで苦しかったのに
これからすごい人生がうまくいって
もう別れた恋人がまた戻ってきてとか
映画だったらもうすごい汚い悪感情なんで
人間はラスベガス行っただけで億万長者にはなれませんね
しかし 自分の命も危険にさらされているのに
なんとかして人こそと助けたことのような映画だったら感情が良いと思いますね
だから貪瞋痴で判断する
貪瞋痴か不貪不瞋痴かと
ちょっと混乱する場合あるかもしれませんよ
はい はい  あの今 ミャンマーの一般市民の方は
サイクロンによって大変な被害を受けているわけですけれども
長老の平和の衝滅という本の中に
軍事政権に一般市民というのは強烈にフェンスのバリアを張られているといった話題があったんですけれども
今日の話の中で 北朝鮮にしても
そういうミャンマーにしても
市民の人たちというのはマインドコントロールをされているということになるんでしょうか
うん そうなんですね やっぱり独裁者はね
厳しくマインドコントロールするんですよ
一人一人人間っていうのは気が弱いでしょ
殺されて欲しくないんですよ
自分の子供を学校から追い出して欲しくないんですよね
その弱みを握っちゃうんですね
自由がないんです マインドコントロールです
政治家は大体マインドコントロールにはものすごい力を入れてます
どんな政治家でもね アメリカの選挙運動を見ても
マインドコントロールばっかりでしょ
やってるのは カッコつけたり
あれやこれやとかね ろくなことは言わないんですね
あれほど金かけてちょっとスローガンばっかりずらざらと並べて
みんなものすごく歓声を上げれば OK やと
バカバカらしいんです
だから政治世界ではね
マインドコントロールかなり働いてます
はい  どうぞ マイクもらって
お客商売をやっているものなんですが
お客さんに対してですね
感謝の気持ちを持とうというような気持ちを持つことも薄かない部分がありまして
先日 お客様はこの商品を欲しがってるんだなと冷静に考えて
それをこちらの方もお客さんのニーズに合うように行った方がいいなというふうに考えたら気楽になったので
やっぱりお客さんに対しの気持ちを持つというのも
やっぱり感情のしがらみですか
あれこれやと思うこと自体緊張することだから楽しくないでしょ
だから楽しみなんですね
必要なのは なんとなく楽しみな仕事をすると
お客さんからの関わりで何か楽しみがなくなっていくなとわかった瞬間で
何かをしてすぐ楽しみを見つかるというかね
楽しみは楽しむんですよ
あれこれやとか 理屈で考えなくてもいいんです
その方が楽になりますし
うまく仕事はいきます
楽しみでやってるんだから
仕事はだらしないということはありえないんです
楽しみだからこそ 仕事はしっかりするんです
例えばうまく仕事をしたことも楽しみにする
うまくいったぞと ああ
よかったと そういうふうなことで
いつでもこの脳に楽しみをフィードインしなくちゃいけないんです
これ 栄養なんです 今 我々の人生が栄養失調でもう死につくす存勢ですね
それはやっぱり楽しみをフィーリングフィーリングというかね
まあ注入して注入して健康にならなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで 楽しみでやるっていうことなんです
答えは はい  他の方よろしいでしょうか
はい マイク  一番後ろ  集中力の話に関連するんですけど
はい 日常生活で結構時間に追われるというか
制限時間以内に仕事を終えないといけないとか
何時までにこれをしないといけないということがあると思うんですけど
集中力との関わりの中で
そういった時間と集中力との関係というのは
長老はどのようにお考えなんでしょうか
集中力があると別に時間に合わせますよ
あの まあそれも一つの挑戦にしてね
楽しくやればいいんです
じゃあ時間をもう全くもう度外視してということでしょうか
時間を忘れないといけないんでしょうか
うーん まあ時間に引っかかるというよりは
もう時間内で終了するっていうことでしょ
だから自分がもう自分の仕事に集中して
さすいわゆる無駄なことを何もしないで
挑戦だっていうことで
さっさとやることなんだ
ゲームで考えてみればどうです？時々ゲームもあるでしょ
時間制限で随分 1分以内でいろんなことやらなくちゃいけない
だからむちゃくちゃやるで
その時は で 楽しいでしょ
その場合は このゲームはできないでしょ
こんな 1 分以内で 2 分以内でとか
1時間欲しいやという人はいません
1時間だったら誰でもできるということですからね
だから人生の場合でも
時間は一応社会では制限するでしょ
決めるでしょ 私たちはわかったとかね
わかったぞという感じで挑戦すればいいと思いますよ
まるっきり無視することもできませんですからね
時間は だから時間内で終了するのは自分にかかっている挑戦なんです
挑戦として受けてみると
もうゲームですからね
楽しくなるんです とにかくこの時間でやってやるぞという感じでね
めちゃくちゃやればうまくいくし
楽しくはなるんです で
まあこれは人によっていろいろあるかもしれませんだけど
私は一般論で喋ってますし
そちらは時間だと何考えてるかちょっとわからないんですけど
まあ一応時間内で終わってください
なぜならば 次の時間で別な仕事あるんだからね
食べる時間でも仕事をしちゃう
食べる時間なくなるでしょう
やっぱり その時間内で仕事をっていうのは
やるべきことを終了するのは普通なんです
9時にお風呂に入るべきなのに
まあまあまあガタガタガタガタしていて
お風呂に入る時は 12時になると寝る時間がなくなっているはずなんですね
そういうことで 時間を無駄にすることが
仏教もすごい厳しく思うんですね
時間を無駄にすることというのは罪だと
悪いんだと 時間に追われることは神経質で楽しみがないんです
それも良くないんです
時間内でやってやることが楽しみなんです
そういうふうなことで
長官的な立場を理解してください
時間に追われるのもよくない
下手ということ 能力ない
時間を無駄にすることは罪
人は堕落する それはどちらでもいかないで
時間をないでしっかりと仕事を終了してみせると
そこはもうゲーム感覚で受け取れば楽しくできると思います
はい 以上です  ありがとうございました
では 他にご質問なければ
もう一人もう一人だけ大丈夫です
あのちょっと手は  先ほど集中力を養う方法の 3つ目で
瞑想もいいけれども 音楽とか体調が悪くないというふうにおっしゃったんですけども
肩をやってみますと バランス感覚が良くなったり
呼吸が深くなったり 体が動いて集中力が高まるんじゃないかと私は思っているんですけども
どうして良くないのか
その理由を  あの本物の集中力もありませんが
落ち着きますよ 当然落ち着きますし
バランス感覚もよろしいかもしれませんだけど
この喜びっていうのはそんな程度のものじゃないんです
ものすごい巨大なものなんです
今日はものすごくカットしましたけど
すごい世界なんです 奇跡的な世界なんです
だからそこは全部なくなりますから
ちょっとちょこちょこっと気持ちよく穏やかでいるだけではね
ちょっともったいないんです
また このいろいろ固定概念
信仰 非科学的なものは割り込んであるんだから
リミットがもうじりじり見えています
だから このプロ中のプロに私も喋ったり話したりすることありましたからね
可哀想やと思うんですよ
本当は これほど有名人でこの程度なのかと
だから今日ははっきり言ってしまったんで
普通は言わないんですけどね
これ悪いとは言わなくて
やってはいけないという意味じゃないんで
当然音楽を聴くと落ち着く人はいる
ちょっとちょっと踊ると気分が良くなる人は当然いる
この気分が良くなっただけで集中力ではないんです
そういうことで この我々は
このレベル破って次元破って集中力というか
喜びを目指しているんですね
喜びに潰されるところまで
それからそれも乗り越えちゃうんですね
冷静になるんです 智慧を開発するんです
そういう長い道があるんです
だから呪文に引っかかっちゃうと
もうもう話にならない
何かしきだりに太鼓を叩くわとなっちゃうと
もうそこでストップになっちゃうんですね
やって悪いじゃなくても
私も誰かマニ車あげて回してください
回してあげますよ 私も教会なんかに行ったり場合はみんなやっていることやります
まあそれはただの普通のね
仕来りであって 行儀作法であってね
本当の心の世界はまたすごい論理的に別なんですね
おっしゃる通りにね 体のバランス
感覚とかは出ますが だから何ということにもなりませんね
で 例えば落ち着きますけど
音楽を聴いて落ち着く
そうすると落ち着くたびに音楽が必要になっちゃうんですね
で 私たちはそうじゃなくて
商店街で落ち着いて歩けます
上の雨除けを歩くときは何のことなくすごく冷静に歩けます
そこで買い物もします
対話をしながらね だからすごく冷静にいられます
その時も しかし冷静でいられるというかではなくて
この慈しみに関わることや
人が苦しんでいることやらね
もう何とかした方がいいんじゃないかって
その時だけはちょっとそこの方向へ感情が出てくるんですね
なんでこうなるのかとかね
慈しみに関わること以外はもうすごい冷静でいられます
特別に何かこういう首にかけるもの
腕にかけるものも首にかけるものもいらなくなりますね
だから自分と一緒にいることが集中力なんですね
そこのためにはね そういうものよりはちゃんとした方法はあるってことなんです
ヨガのことをね よくよく調べてみたんだからね
もう ヨガの先生に聞けば
もう９９パーセントインチキだと言って堂々と言うんだからね
皆様には言わないのはわかります
我々同じ文化圏だから仲間なんですね
だから私は誰かの先生の話を引用すると
あんなのはインチキだからと何のことなく言うんだから
我々は知ってはいるんですけど
一応有名な人だからということでね
色を落としたってもね
一応ブラマン教でバラモン教で
ヒンドゥー教でそれほど瞑想文化が進んでいないんです
彼らが人のものはパクっただけ
瞑想世界は仏教とジャイナ教だけなんです
ジャイナ教は苦行に陥ったんだから戦場はなかったんです
瞑想の世界はものすごく分析している文献といえば仏教だけなんです
仏教の本を 読んでヨーガ・スートラやらあれこれと書かれましたけど
でもまあそんなに明確じゃないんで
読んでみたらあんまり面白くなかったんですね
まあ理性でいいんですよ
誰が本当のことを言ってるかわかりませんだから
誰の話でも理性で考えればいいっていうことなんです
理性で自由になります
で 私は今日言ったのは
このものすごいレベル破って得られる
もう巨大な楽しみというものは
普通のヨーガ瞑想では花をこちら回ったり
こちらやったりということでは生まれません
で 一つの花でオーって言って唱えたってもね
で またこういろいろやったりしてね
まあそれではしきたりなんですね
しきたりに惹かれるとの瞑想はできなくなりますよと書いてましたからね
病みつきになりますね
そんなことをやっちゃうと
それもある程度集中力なんですね
はい まあということで
結論は言えませんだけどね
まあその程度 じゃあ終了しましょうか
時間なくなりますので
では祝福経典をあげますので
合掌してみてください
サッビーティヨーヴィパッジャンツーサンバローゴーウィナッサトゥマーテーバワットワンテラーヨースキィディーガーユコーババトゥサッバマンガランガッカントゥ
サンバデヴァタサンバブッダヌーバヴェーナサンバダンマヌーバヴェーナサッバサンガヌーバヴェーナサダソッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリッサーニッチャン
ワッダパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーワッダンティーアーユアンノーシュカンバラン
では 長い時間どうもありがとうございます